hi there this is a short one but we find
here we find the Bonjour that we're
already familiar with Colonel Sava this
is a more familiar way of saying come on
today whoo
come on Sava get used to it
how are you Saavik Libya it goes well
yeah come on up up up wha notice that
we're in a more informal environment
here so how is it going for you
4:12 there is one thing to notice in
French is that we have an informal - and
a more formal vous which is also the
plural of course come on tobacco fly to
LA byung-se all is good fine
now one thing that's introduced here is
the past tense occupy see have you spent
occupy say and we start to see how the
French form questions they reverse the
order to apply say you have spent but I
to pass a humble weekend now this might
be a little controversial because in
France they say weekend but in Quebec
they say fans of cement which means end
of the week so both are quite ok the MSE
of course is a term you know most of us
know that in French we know the word kV
yeah very good yeah the guttural are in
French causes people problems let your
brain get use the language to listen
listening to the language you can try
pronouncing it early on but I wouldn't
worry too much about it in fact I find
that often it's useful to just to let
the language flow in and wait a month or
so before you try to start to pronounce
these some of these sounds that may seem
a little new and different